hooray Saturday was the White House
Correspondents Dinner here's a clip it's
a trash fire we could stop there now
everything went as planned the comedian
and undiluted leftist plucked from The
Daily Show assembly line of press
approved
Prague's unloaded on the White House but
like a tortoise on crutches you could
see the jokes limping toward you the
dinners now just old news an orgy of
self-congratulation
selfies and predictable Barb's masked as
edgy like the Sarah sander stuff I have
to say I'm a little star-struck I love
you as aunt Lydia in The Handmaid's Tale
I actually really liked Sarah I think
she's very resourceful like she burns
facts and then she uses that Ash to
create a perfect smoky eye like maybe
she's born with it maybe it's lies it's
probably life and I'm not really sure
what to call Sarah Huckabee Sanders you
know is it Sarah Sanders is it Sarah
Huckabee Sanders like what's Uncle Tom
but for white women who disappoint other
white women now Woolf reminds us that
you can smear women as long as you're on
the right side politically the media
calls that a roast if you did it it
would be called misogyny but Prague's
play by different rules take joy read
whatever she wrote will be excused by
people who would crucify you for much
much less being on the left excuses
everything you can drive girls into the
drink or run the Klan and still sit in
the Senate as long as you're a Democrat
now the comics
if the comics defenders will say but
Trump said bad things about women to
your rights he said bad things about
everyone but if he wasn't president and
Marco Rubio was you think Michelle would
be any nicer to Rubio he's pro-life
she's this Mike Pence is also very anti
choice
he thinks abortion is murder which first
of all don't knock it till you try it
and when you do try it really knock it
you know you gotta get that baby out of
there
maybe that's what brian Stelter
considers brave material take that
unborn baby
so yeah Trump has said bad things but he
crushed Isis and might just solve a
sixty-year-old problem called North
Korea I'll take that trade-off even if I
must listen to really bad jokes once a
year so should you
Kimberly I go to you because I believe
you feel strongly about this topic am I
correct yes because you were monitoring
me all weekend in my tweets yes correct
yes I was outside your house all right
so I have to tell you Smee I felt that
this was so mean-spirited that it wasn't
anything that was like comedic about it
there was nothing to be gained for her
saying these type of things that were
directly targeted at Sarah Sanders I
think majority of what she had to say
went against her this is an advancing
women this isn't even advancing the
First Amendment this is just proffering
cruelty and I think if you were sitting
in a chair like that to listen to that
and everybody basically some people I
guess left etc but to allow it even to
continue to go on in this way I thought
it was absolutely terrible I didn't
attend it you know we were all invited
we didn't go well you you went I think
you're the only one of the five of us
right okay and so on I'll say what his
we know personal experience was being
there and actually listening to in the
room sometimes it's a little different
but at home and I rewatched it so many
times and I felt so sad for her it's
just one of those things and Sarah
conducted herself you know beautifully
and really handled herself well to sit
there and listen to these things so
mean-spirited bullying that's what it is
I wouldn't like it if she said that
about you know a man a woman a child but
to do that what did Sarah Sanders ever
do to her to deserve those kind of
personal attacks and that level of
vitriol I mean she should feel horrible
about herself when she goes to bed and
she wakes up in the morning Michelle
wolf because none of that was funny
whatsoever
well you okay Dana she the day would
probably respond that a Sarah because
Trump wasn't there Sarah she becomes the
target she's the proxy and number two
Trump has said things about you know
people's faces
twice so it's like and some people laugh
yeah yeah and I just like just across
the board I don't think it's good or
funny the interesting thing about this
is that just two months ago or three
months ago the president went to the
gridiron dinner and he it was when the
first of these that he's attended he
brought the house down he's very funny
speech was great Nancy Pelosi was one of
the speakers I think she I think that
was her that night and then Tom cotton
usually if you have an elected leader
who has to and it's not easy to give a
speech like that and they go through
they have to practice and it costs
actually a lot because you've usually
farm it out to some great speech writer
and I don't think Washington DC needs to
bring in anyone from the outside to do
these types of yeah they just the
gridiron dinner has never done it it is
always fantastic the line that they have
is the the gridiron singes but it never
burns I do hope that that's the last of
the sound bites that I have to hear
that's the voice is really it gets to me
Craig Ferguson was one of the only
comedians there that I thought was so
gentle because he basically just made
fun of himself the entire time and he
complimented me so that was I remember
that but your thing is when she talks
about the abortion joke yeah you know
one thing you could say in response is
that well at least she called it a baby
yeah I think that was the biggest flaw
also now now you think it's a baby yeah
we're gonna take that to the Congress
yep no that's that was I think that was
a big flaw and heard and heard
undermined her joke also to your point
you know Obama gives great speeches they
don't need a detenida comedian usually
the the elected leaders who give funny
speeches are usually actually not even
elected leader Laura Bush when she did
it the one year at the White House
Correspondents Dinner it was hilarious
when she called herself a desperate
housewife and everybody got it and you
don't need to bring in somebody from the
outside of DC yeah Jesse with you Dana
should be no more let the president do
it like when President Obama spoke he
was very funny was very entertaining
guess what people would actually go then
no one wants to sit there and listen to
this nonsense yeah Jesse not a rousing
success no a Roseanne Barr said the
first rule of comedy you don't target
someone in the audience who's more
famous than you are you'll lose the
entire crowd and this is what happens
you book a c-list comedian to make fun
of the DC a-listers look who they've had
the last couple years Cecily strong
Larry Wilmore Hasan Minhaj Michelle wolf
I've never even heard of any of these
people at all daily show these people
are not famous committed look who they
had during a stretch of Obama Conan
Jimmy Kimmel Seth Meyers Jay Leno look
at the stretch under Bush Colbert Cedric
the Entertainer Jay Leno Jew Carroll you
know they'd say that Colbert actually
ended up with a prime-time late-night
show because partly because of that
career so in that case I blame the White
House Correspondents Association for him
but let's be honest the delivery was
terrible it was average material the
voice was not good I'm glad we said it
and I didn't have to say first but the
point is is that I blame the White House
Correspondents in our association for
this they knew what they were getting
into when they booked this yeah I agree
but this is who the left is they have
been smearing and hurting conservatives
and trafficking and this kind of hateful
unfunny stuff for the last year but on
the show for an entire year we've had
montages this stuff from Chelsea Handler
going after Melania - I think the
assassination jokes with Kathy Griffin
and Johnny Depp you've had Chris
Matthews say horrible things would they
say on Morning Joe the swear words on
CNN it's been despicable throughout the
entire year no one has ever condemned
that and here's the reasons why they
condemned at this time it was done in
their room it was done a dare dinner by
a comedian who they hired and it was
done to the person's face all the other
hateful stuff was on Twitter it was on
someone else's show they didn't have to
take responsibility the reason they had
to condemn this comedian now was because
it was a PR problem for them they were
only doing it for that reason in that
reason alone you know in the why to that
point do you think that the White House
Correspondents Association which were
cowardly for for distancing themselves I
don't think they should have distanced
themselves they made the decision to
have her there they should have
supported her I think yeah and I think
they must be reacting to some backlash
that they proceeded and I think the
backlash to my mine is someone who was
there and who was saying there was no
one walking out by the way was that you
had Sarah Huckabee Sanders sitting on
the stage I believe she was two people
removed from the lectern and she's
sitting there and even
the TV cameras then enlarge the
perspective so you could see Sanders
reacting to miss wolf and the problem
was that it just felt unfair to her I
thought you know I saw Sarah Huckabee
Sanders later and I held her hand said
you're on III think you have a great
sense of humor because in the moment you
worried that she was gonna burst into
tears or stand up and walk out and then
it'd be a whole deal about that and
that's not what the White House
Correspondents Association wants for
their event where I disagree with you
guys this she was hilarious
I think she was genius funny I mean and
you that you don't understand she was
picking on the press a lot she was
picking on Democrat sheep I mean she
said about the idea that Franken is gone
she said Ted Kennedy probably says hey I
murdered a girl yeah like kind of thing
that was a good job you know what and I
think when I sit here with all you guys
you talk about liberal intolerance for a
variety of voices and speech well gee
here's a variety of where here's a
different perspective and she went after
and probably her most telling thing was
she said you know you guys in the press
you created this monster and now you're
all making but your books your art your
podcast your TV shows making money and
you don't ever say but you love all you
want to talk about is krump and Russia
that was directly at the end that was
good part and then another good part was
when she went after white women and I'd
never heard anything like this she says
hey you think about what's going on oh
not only with Sarah Huckabee Sanders but
you think about Kellyanne Conway you
think about Ivanka everybody says oh
women's issues are gonna be the
forefront she says you guys have
disappointed white women and she's
called him Uncle Tom right in terms of
white work to me this was like everybody
let me tell you where I was saying
people were laughing well maybe you were
at a different table because she lost a
crowd early nah and she bombed and
there's so much good material about the
Trump White House from acosta to Twitter
to the Russians to Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer it's so easy to make a nice even
clean joke majority of this stuff was
very dirty and I can handle dirty jokes
everybody there can handle dirty jokes I
think it takes more talent to be clean
almost everything was filthy alright and
yeah if you can be mean but the jokes
have to land
Jesse saying that he can do it but the
resident said he wants Greg to do it and
you know Donald Trump had a suggestion
how to make the night better and it was
the so-called comedian really bombed
Greg Gutfeld should host next year so I
am saying yes to the challenge I will
host next year but but not there we have
to do a counter dinner maybe do it for
police widows the money goes there and
it's and then Trump has to go to that
challenge so truck search up I will take
you up on this offer and I'm gonna do
this but we it has to be a different
event at the same time different
charities and and and it'll still be a
roast but it'd be a general gross you
might have a rally scheduled yeah you
know I remember when I must went after
the Clintons oh yeah about extramarital
yeah right with mrs. Klein oh it was
hard how about Larry Wilmore using the
n-word in front of Obama Oh dad see I
remember doing mottos on all of these a
comedian there they just use themselves
would be far funnier to be quite honest
he's great at the rallies he's great
when he gets up and spoke at the
gridiron thing like Dana said and that
wasn't like mean-spirited yeah and it
could all be their own punchlines that's
the fun part